bonjour à tous je vais donc essayer de
répondre à la question avec un angle un
peu particulier qui est le lien entre le
système économique dans lequel nous
insérons et l'énergie alors je suis
désolé je vais commencer par faire un
tout petit rappel de physique vous savez
quand on parle d'énergie aux gens ils
vont comprendre facture d'électricité
facture de gaz
un certain nombre d'entre eux vont
comprendre plein de ma voiture c'est
rare qu'ils se rappellent de la ride
définition qu'ils ont dû singur jt quand
il était sur les bancs de l'école
alors je vais vous l'a rappelé même si
c'est un souvenir très désagréable
l'énergie c'est par définition la marque
du changement d'état d'un système
ça veut dire quoi ce charabia ça veut
dire que quand le monde physique autour
de nous change quel que soit le
changement il ya de l'énergie qui est
intervenue alors dans les actes de la
vie courante un certain nombre de choses
sont faciles à visualiser et sont
faciles à associer à d'énergie quand
vous avez par exemple un changement de
température quelque part il ya de
l'énergie qui intervient que ce soit
pour réchauffer ou pour refroidir
quand vous avez un changement vitesse
d'un objet typiquement une voiture qui
se met en mouvement
vous avez de l'énergie qui intervient
quand vous avez un changement de forme
choses qui se passent dans n'importe
quelle usine qui travail de la matière
vous avez de l'énergie qui intervient
quand vous avez une composition chimique
qui change ce qui est arrivé aussi dans
un certain nombre d' usine ou dans votre
estomac et dans votre propre corps vous
avez de l'énergie qui intervient ça
c'est un peu plus compliqué quand vous
avez un corps qui se déplace dans un
chant typiquement vous dans le champ
gravitationnel il ya de l'énergie qui
intervient vous savez que monter sur une
montagne c'est dur parce que il faut
fournir de l'énergie pour lutter contre
la gravitation
quand vous avez une composition atomique
qui change vous avez de l'énergie qui
intervient c'est grâce à ça que le
soleil nous envoie du rayonnement et
enfin ce qui vous a particulièrement
occupé jusqu'au 31 août
quand de la matière et du rayonnement
interagissent vous avez de l'énergie qui
intervient alors une version plus
utilitaire et plus quotidienne de ça
c'est le four à micro ondes
le four à micro-ondes envoi du
rayonnement sur quelque chose et
transferts l'énergie et ça chauffe
donc l'énergie c'est par définition le
changement du monde qui nous entoure
alors une des conclusions une première
conclusion qu'on peut tirer de cette
affaire c'est que l'énergie propre ça
n'existe pas ce qu'un changement propre
ça n'existe pas vous avez des
changements intéressants des changements
qu'ils sont moins c'est une affaire de
nature de changement de bénéfices
d'inconvénients du changement et c'est
l'énergie propre n'existe pas vous vous
rendez compte que l'énergie propre dans
les médias c'est souvent l'énergie qui
n'existe pas encore ou qui existe à
toute petite dose et la deuxième
conclusion que je peux vous proposer
c'est qu'il n'existe pas de système
productif sans énergie c'est pas
possible parce qu'un système productif
c'est un système de transformation notre
monde économique est un monde de
transformation et donc dès que vous avez
une production quelque part vous avez de
l'énergie donc avant même de dépendre
d'un prix le système économique dépend
de l'énergie en volume dépend de
l'existence même de l'énergie un petit
calcul d'ordre de grandeur
on n'est pas très loin de la bretagne
ici donc je prends un breton des temps
anciens
un petit calcul d'ordre de grandeur pour
vous montrer à quel point aujourd'hui
nous sommes devenus des nababs grâce à
l'énergie
au regard de ce qui était la condition
des hommes des temps pas si anciens que
ça dure est alors je prends mon
touristes des temps anciens je lui colle
un petit sac à dos tout ça c'est juste
pour que le calcul soit plus facile et
je dis que simon touristes qui pèse 100
kg avec son sac à dos monde sur une
montagne qui fait 2000 mètres de
dénivelé donc tous ceux qui ont fait de
la montagne dans la salle apprécieront à
2022 dénivelé dans la journée au général
j'avais un peu faim la fin de la journée
et bien en faisant ça avec ses jambes
avec les bras c'est plus dur mon
touristes des temps anciens aura fourni
une énergie mécanique qui est d'un demi
kilo watt heure alors pour tous ceux
d'entre vous qui ont vu le nombre de
kilowattheures sur une facture
d'électricité ou de gaz sinon je vous
invite à le faire là vous faites ce
genre d'effort sur une journée un
ridicule demi kilowattheure admettons
que je sois intéressés par des gens
juste pour le travail mécanique qui sont
capables de me fournir
et bien ce quelqu'un qui fait
fonctionner ses jambes toute la journée
un jour sur deux ou un jour sur trois
parce que peu de gens dans la salle sont
capables de faire ça tous les jours que
dieu fait eh bien je vais obtenir de
l'ordre de 100 kilowatts heure d'énergie
mécanique à la fin de la journée
à la fin de l'année pardon donc je fais
travailler mes gens très très dure une
année haillan
poussant sur les jambes 100 kilowatts
heure d'énergie le même raisonnement
vous amène au fait que si j'utilise des
bras et plutôt ceux de sortie n'est
guère que les miens sur une année là je
vais pas récupérer 100 kilowatts heure
j'ai plus de récupérer 10 10 ridicule
kilowattheure maintenant je prends un
litre d'essence dont chacun sait que le
prix est scandaleusement élevés
insupportable qu'il faut le bc et bien
dans un litre d'essence
vous avez dit kilowattheures d'énergie
quand vous le faites brûler et quand
vous faites passer ça dans un moteur qui
est jamais un rendement de 100 % vous
récupérer à l'arrivée 2 à 4 kilowatts
heure d'énergie mécanique doit 4 ce qui
veut dire que dans 1 litre d'essence
vous avez la même capacité à transformer
l'environnement une fois que c'est passé
dans un moteur que dans 10 jours de
travail de force de quelqu'un qui
utilise ses bras ses jambes pardon ou
100 jours de travail de force de
quelqu'un qui utilise ses bras un litre
d'essence
dix ouvriers qui utilisent leurs jambes
une journée sans ouvriers qui utilisent
leurs bras une journée fabuleux fabuleux
et ça ne vaut rien mon litre d'essence
pour un peu plus d'un euro
si je paye mes ouvriers au smic ce que
la loi normalement m'oblige à faire
eh bien je vais payer mon kilowattheures
d'énergie mécanique quelques centaines
d'euros à quelques milliers d'euros
selon que j'utilise des jambes ou des
bras
c'est à dire que par la magie des
combustibles fossiles
je suis capable de transformer
l'environnement pour quelques centaines
à quelques milliers de fois moins cher
quand j'utilise la machine qui mangent
du pétrole ou du gaz du charbon de
l'uranium que quand j'utilise les gens
la formidable hausse de la productivité
du travail dont je suis sûr qu'un
certain nombre de gens dans cette salle
voit ce terme imprimé sur le journal à
peu près tous les jours c'est
essentiellement une affaire de mise à
disposition de stocks fabuleux d'énergie
qui sont gratuits puisque les
combustibles fossiles ont été formés
gratuitement au cours de l'évolution des
temps sans que qui que ce soit dans
cette salle ne payent moins de centimes
ce qui a fait notre pouvoir d'achat et
tout le reste c'est ça admettons que je
sois un patron pas social du tout donc
pas monsieur de romanet qui vous a parlé
j'ai des esclaves alors l'esclave vous
savez la définition de l'esclave c'est
qu'on ne paye pas ça la définition de
l'esclave cela étant nous sommes dans
une société méchante donc il faut
l'acheter et
il faut les empêcher de mourir donc ça
vous coûte le fait de le nourrir de
l'empêcher de mourir de froid de choses
et c est bien quand vous faites le
calcul vous vous rendez compte que même
ça ça va vous coûter 10 à 100 fois plus
cher que le travail de la machine
conclusion qui peut vous paraître
peut-être un peu cynique je pense que l'
esclavage n'a pas disparu parce que nous
sommes devenus bon je pense que l'
esclavage a disparu parce que c'est anti
économiques comparées à la machine par
ailleurs quand vous voyez la différence
de prix entre le travail et l'énergie
vous vous rendez compte que n'importe
quelle dépense d'énergie qui remplace
n'importe quelle quantité de travail est
une bonne affaire
d'où mécanisation mondialisation
automatisation et c'est tout ça c'est de
la rationalité économique de base dans
le monde dans lequel nous vivons
d'énergie grâce encore une fois aux
ressources disponibles sur terre on en
consomme de plus en plus alors vous avez
sur ce petit graphique la quantité de
kilowattheures consommés par personne et
par an en moyenne mondiale depuis un
siècle et demi donc un siècle et demi
ces six générations assez pas beaucoup
pour une espèce qui en a connu quelques
milliers ou quelques dizaines de
milliers et vous voyez quand six
générations
on est passé d'à peu près mille 500
kilowatts heure par personne et par an
en moyenne mondiale a à peu près 20
milles
vous voyez que les énergies s'empilent
les unes sur les autres donc il ya très
peu de cannibalisme et ses énergies
renouvelables qui est excitant les
journalistes français c'est le petit
truc bleus là que vous avez tout en haut
de la courbe d'accord et retenez cette
petite maxime sur les énergies
renouvelables c'est plus journal en
parle moyens là dans le monde
c'est valable le charbon est une énergie
du présent pas du tout du passé parce
que ça sert à faire de l'électricité
c'est la première source
c'est la première énergie utilisée pour
produire de l'électricité dans le monde
le pétrole qui est l'énergie reine des
transports par excellence et de se
rajouter par dessus et c'est alors je
vais vous enquiquiner avec un petit
chiffre pendant un siècle
chaque terrien à disposer chaque année
d'environ 2 % d'énergie en plus que
l'année précédente
pendant un siècle ce qui veut dire que
toutes choses égales par ailleurs chaque
terrien était capable de transformer son
environnement et donc de produire des
fourchettes des tables des couteaux et
cetera 2% de plus que l'année précédente
toutes choses égales par ailleurs sans
même parler de progrès technique comme
chaque année vous moi tout le monde
pouvait transformer l'environnement 2%
de plus c'est ça l'augmentation de la
productivité du travail
en tout cas c'est un des termes depuis
les chocs pétroliers ça s'est
considérablement tassée en fête les
chocs pétroliers ont marqué une rupture
de pente extrêmement fortes sur
l'approvisionnement énergétique par
personne et ces deux là j'aurais
malheureusement pas le temps de
développer aujourd'hui que sont venus à
mon avis l'essentiel des problèmes
économiques que nous connaissons
aujourd'hui et qui datent de cette
époque là le début du chômage le début
de l'endettement le début du
ralentissement de la hausse de la
productivité du travail et c'est sur
quoi tout un tas de doctes médecin digne
de molière parfois se penche en disant
c'était une crise du crédit c'est une
crèche pourquoi non moi je pense que
c'est avant tout une crise de l'énergie
il n'en reste pas moins que aujourd'hui
chacun jacques terriens à de l'ordre de
20 mille kilowatts heure par personne à
sa disposition sur l'année si nous
n'avions pas les combustibles fossiles
donc si tout le confort moderne était
procurés par des gens utilisant leurs
jambes et leurs bras et bien un terrien
devrait avoir l'équivalent de 200
esclaves à sa disposition en permanence
pour vivre de la même manière et en
france on est plutôt à 600 en france on
est plutôt à 6 ans la france
on vous l'a dit tout à l'heure utilise
du nucléaire certes elle utilise sur
tout autre chose
vous avez ici la décomposition par type
d'énergie et par usage en france et tout
ce que je viens de cercle et en bleu
provient des combustibles fossiles c'est
à dire pétrole et gaz pour l'essentiel
un tout petit peu de charbon dans ce
pays notre pays est avant tout un pays
fossiles
enfin au sens des combustibles avant
tout un pays facile le nucléaire est un
élément très important du paysage
énergétique français
il n'empêche que ça c'est très loin
d'être le seul et quand on regarde
l'électricité soit dit en passant c'est
pas le chauffage qui domine et en plus
ce nuage des usages de l'électricité
pour le chauffage est un truc à peu près
stable depuis 30 ans ce qui domine c'est
tout le reste c'est tout le reste
alors ce que je viens de vous raconter
au cours de ce petit moment introductif
va m'amener à ça ça c'est quoi c'est la
manière dont encore une fois quand vous
ouvrez les pages économie du journal ou
quand vous entendez monsieur moscovici
ou ses prédécesseurs
on vous parle d'économie on vous dit
l'économie c'est très simple il ya des
gens qui travaillent et y à du capital
donc si le pib flag à douillet que
retraite vont poser un problème pour
booster un peu le pib faut augmenter le
travail il faut augmenter capital simple
donc il faut demander aux banquiers
d'arrêter de faire les zazous et de
financer des usines et il faut former
des gens pour qu'ils soient capables de
travailler
et puis sio si on fait ça le pib
augmentera et on paiera les retraites
alors ça c'est la théorie la pratique
montre que ça marche pas bien puisque
ces dernières années on a injecté des
liquidités on à financer les
investissements etc
le pib par parti pour autant et par
ailleurs du travail on en a trop parce
qu'on a plein de joueurs donc on n'a pas
un problème d'accès à la quantité
il y en a trop donc ce n'est pas ça le
problème en fait le problème c'est qu'on
n'a pas une bonne vue des flux physiques
qui pilotent notre système productif
vous avez ici une représentation
synthétique de ce que c'est vraiment
physiquement qu'un système productif
c'est je prends les ressources et je les
transforme
vous n'avez pas un objet dans cette
salle pas un qui soit autre chose que
des ressources naturelles transformé par
notre activité c'est vrai des vêtements
que vous portez des chaises sur
lesquelles vous êtes assis du matériel
audiovisuel grâce auquel je m'exprime
tout ce que vous allez manger à midi
rentre également dans cette catégorie
c'est encore vrai du moyen de transport
qui vous a amené ici et c'est pas un
objet que vous allez voir aujourd'hui ni
durant toute votre vie ne va être autre
chose que des ressources naturelles
transformé par notre activité
pas d'accord mais ces ressources dans le
dans la convention économique que nous
avons bâti vannes 0 gratuite d'accord
pour ceux d'entre vous qui sont dans des
entreprises
on aurait un système comptable normal on
courait des dotations aux amortissements
des cons utilise des ressources
naturelles comptable dans la nature et
on collerait des provisions pour risques
à chaque fois qu'on fait un truc qui
modifiera plus tard l'environnement avec
éventuellement des dommages associés
c'est parce qu'on fait en macroéconomie
c'est pas du tout ce qu'on fait on
compte la valeur de ce qu'on a produit
en compte pour zéro la valeur de ce
qu'ont à consommer donc la bonne manière
dans le système s'organise vous l'avez
là on a des ressources qu'on transforme
et le capital ça n'est rien d'autre
qu'une partie de la production passée
qui dure et qu'on affecte au profit de
la production future
un typiquement cet immeuble là c'est la
production passée des ressources et du
travail passé star d'éléments de capital
ça va durer et enfin j'espère pour ce
qui nourrit nos v et on va le mettre au
service de la production future
le travail dont je vous rappelle que
c'est une des expressions de l'énergie
en fils
icahn gauche est bien pour un il est
fourni par nos muscles
la transformation est pour 200 par
l'énergie mangés par les machines et
pour 200 par l'énergie mangés par les
machines
1 un ouvrier qui pilote un laminoir
salaires laminoir un gros machin là qui
écrase des brames d'acier et bien le
rapport entre la puissance du laminoir
et la puissance de ses muscles c'est 1 à
1 million donc en fait l'ouvrier joue un
jeu vidéo
il appuie sur des boutons et des
manettes et le laminoir lui obéit il
n'est pas du tout à utiliser ses propres
muscles pour produire de l'acier
d'accord c'est pas ça si vous avez
maintenant une restriction sur l'énergie
en volume
vous aurez une restriction sur la
production en volume on va voir ça juste
après et si vous avez une restriction
sur les ressources vous aurez également
une restriction sur la production si
vous avez une usine flambant neuf et pas
d'énergie pour l'alimenter vous pouvez
avoir votre usine et les travailleurs
vous aurez pas de production
contribution au pib 0 si vous avez lu
zine et vous n'avez pas les ressources
qu'elles transforment contribution au
pib 0 d'accord donc les deux goulets
d'étranglement qui aujourd'hui sont à
l'oeuvre déjà à l'oeuvre déjà à l'oeuvre
c'est précisément ce qu'on ne mesure pas
alors ça c'est la théorie on va passer
au banc d'essai vous avez ici un
graphique qui vous met en perspective la
variation de la quantité d'énergie
consommée dans le monde
année après année c'est la courbe verte
donc ce n'est pas la quantité d'énergie
consommée c'est sa variation d'accord
d'une année sur l'autre et en bleu vous
avez la variation du pib mondial d'une
année sur l'autre et vous voyez que ce
qu'on constate sur ce graphique est très
exactement très exactement cohérent avec
ce que je viens de vous raconter sur les
ordres de grandeurs comparée du travail
et de l'énergie
autres représentations des mêmes données
vous avez ici des points chaque point
correspond à une année en bas à gauche
vous êtes an 65 en haut à droite en 2012
et pour chaque année j'ai regardé en
abscisse combien le monde avait
consommer d'énergie et en ordonnée
qu'elle avait été le pib en dollars
constants ça marche beaucoup mieux que
les modèles macroéconomiques de bercy
donc vous avez aujourd'hui un
asservissement très fort
encore un exemple ici vous avez en rouge
la variation de la production mondiale
de pétrole d'une
année sur l'autre en fait c'est une
moyenne lissée sur trois ans peu importe
c'est la variation de la production
mondiale de pétrole et en bleu vous avez
la variation du pib par personne en
moyenne mondiale
regardez bien ce qui s'est passé sur les
deux derniers épisodes là et là le
pétrole varient avant le pib
dit autrement ça n'accréditent pas
l'hypothèse qui est on consomme moins de
pétrole parce que c'est la crise
chronologiquement ce qui se passe c'est
que vous avez d'abord moins de pétrole
et ensuite c'est la crise
si vous regardez tous les pays de
l'europe du sud c'est les pays en europe
qui ont la plus grande part de pétrole
dans leur mix énergétique 60% en grèce
50 % en espagne 50 % au portugal
50 % en irlande aussi soit dit en
passant et c'est ces pays là qu'ils se
sont enfoncés le plus profondément dans
la crise et dans tous ces pays le
pétrole comment adecco mance à descendre
deux ans avant le pib dans tous ces pays
alors je pourrais malheureusement là
aussi j'ai pas le temps vous donner les
explications qui montre que c'est assez
normal que le pétrole soit un signe
avant-coureur du pib donc si je résume
ce que je viens de dire mère-nature a
fourni grâce à quelques centaines de
millions d'années d'évolution des
combustibles fossiles gratuits qui sont
aussi gratuite le vent et le soleil
d'accord ce qui coûte c'est d'y accéder
et de payer la paire la personne qui a
eu la bonne idée de naître au dessus
d'accord ça ça coûte
la création de ces combustibles 00
d'accord ils sont gratuits
ils sont aussi gratuit que le vent et le
soleil aussi gratuit donc ces
combustibles gratuit brûle ça nous a
donné les moteurs et la chimie qui nous
ont donné la totalité de ce qui nous
entoure et la totalité de ce qui nous
entoure a permis de structurer le monde
peut-être que nous connaissons grâce à
la productivité du travail agricole vous
êtes assis dans cette salle à devoir
vous farcir ce que je vous raconte
au lieu d'être occupés à faire pousser
des patates parce que la productivité de
la culture des patates est devenue telle
que vous avez le temps de faire des
études longues des emplois de bureaux
des retraites et c'est donc le monde que
nous avons bâti et qu'ils seront tous
les pays industrialisés villes de la
même manière indépendamment du fait
qu'ils aient élu des gens de gauche de
droite du centre du milieu d'en haut
d'en bas de verre à paillettes j'sais
pas quoi ils vivent tous de la même
manière parce que l'énergie à structurer
les flux physiques chez ces gens là
de la même manière partout partout on a
concentré des gens dans les villes on a
fait des emplois de bureau on a étalé
les banlieues
gens roulent en voitures partout alors
que parce que partout il ya de l'énergie
alors il ya deux questions qui se posent
à partir de là la première c'est alors
elle a été rapidement évoquée par la
personne qui a fait l'introduction avec
quelques petites inexactitudes sait
combien de temps est-ce que je peux
continuer à tirer de manière croissante
des combustibles fossiles du sol je vais
vous donner trois indications là dessus
deuxième question qui est le pendant
aval de la même question combien de
temps est-ce que je peux rajouter dans
l'atmosphère une espèce chimiques qui
s'appelle le co2 qui reste parce qu'elle
est chimiquement très stable donc elle
s'en va pas vite une fois cueillies dans
l'atmosphère et dans l'atmosphère et qui
a la particularité d'être opaque aux
infrarouges terrestre et qui engendre
donc ce qu'on a coutume d'appeler le
changement climatique c'est la question
à mon et la question aval d'un même
processus qui est celui qui pilote le
pib alors quand je vous dis ça vous
comprenez évidemment que limité
volontairement les émissions de co2
toutes choses égales par ailleurs c'est
limité volontairement le pouvoir d'achat
ça pose des problèmes d'implémentation
qui ne sont pas simples mais c'est bien
de ça dont on parle alors la bonne
nouvelle c'est qu'il va dit milieu de
toute façon ce qui va nous éviter des
états d'âme alors on va y aller donc la
première partie c'est à dire combien de
temps est-ce que je peux avoir un flux
croissant en provenance du sol
là encore il faut revenir à des
mathématiques simples mon stock de
départ il est donnée une fois pour
toutes d'accord il faut 300 millions
d'années pour faire du gaz ou du pétrole
enfin entre 50 et 300 donc au début de
la civilisation industrielle qui va
durer quelques siècles ou quelques
milliers d'années j'ai un stock de
départ dans le sol là je ne connais pas
bien mais c'est pas grave il est fixé
une fois pour toutes d'accord alors on
va prendre un parallèle vous héritez
vous héritez d'un capital donc c'est une
quantité d'euros qui va pas augmenter
derrière d'accord quantité d'euros qui
arrive sur votre compte
eh bien vous êtes d'accord avec moi que
cette quantité d'euros vous pouvez pas
chaque jour en dépenser une fraction
croissante d'accords vous pouvez pas
chaque jour dépenser de plus en plus
d'euro indéfiniment à partir de cet
héritage que vous et vos descendants à
partir de cet héritage nous avait reçus
corse pas possible vous ne pouvez même
pas dépenser chaque jour la même chose
jusqu'à la nuit des temps même ça c'est
pas possible
en fait les mathématiques vous impose ça
se démontre que en pareil cas
vos dépenses vont partir de zéro terminé
à 0 est passé par un maximum c'est
exactement pareil pour le pétrole les
mathématiques impose que l'extraction de
pétrole de terre par 2 0 c'est facile il
ya 3000 ans n'en extrayaient pas un jour
ça sera zéro au plus tard quand tu auras
plus d'hommes et il va y avoir un
maximum entre les deux est la bonne
question c'est quand comment à quel
niveau et est ce que c'est grave docteur
ou est-ce que c'est pas grave docteur
d'accord c'est sur les bonnes questions
soit dit en passant cette loi est
valable pour tous les minerais tous les
minerais il ya un stock de départ qui
donne une fois pour toutes on ne refait
pas en continu du minerai de cuivre du
minerai de plomb du minerai de zinc ou
du minerai de nickel le stock sous terre
il est donnée une fois pour toutes
et donc il y aura également des courbe
en cloche pour les extractions de tous
les minerais qui aujourd'hui servent nos
activités industrielles
donc nous aurons un truc qui va
s'appeler le pic voilà c'est pas une
support un truc idéologique fumeux c'est
juste un théorème de match
si je regarde le pétrole voilà d'où nous
venons voilà où nous allons et nous
sommes ici
donc vous voyez le maximum mondial il
était peut-être la semaine dernière il
sera peut-être dans trois ans et après
un bon bref en gros on y est en tout cas
on y est vraiment au sens de déplacer
les systèmes de transport sur le pétrole
s'est essentiellement les systèmes de
transports l'urbanisme les organisations
industrielles et les métiers qui vont
avec c'est un truc qui prend plus d'une
semaine donc que le pic soit ya cinq ans
où qu'ils soient dans dix ans le
problème se pose exactement la même
manière exactement de la même manière la
question à laquelle tout le monde pense
en pareil cas c'est quoi ça va valoir
et je vais vous expliquer que c'est une
bonne question pour les français est une
question sans importance en ce qui
concerne l'économie mondiale alors
parlons des français et par l'ong europe
vous avez ici l'approvisionnement
pétrolier de l'europe depuis 1965 avant
tout à l'heure on nous a dit enfin la
personne qui a fait l'introduction a dit
olympiques on nous en parle pour plus
tard une bonne nouvelle pour vous pour
l'europe le pic est passé d'accord le
voilà vous avez en rose la production de
la mer du nord envers nos importations
qui aujourd'hui représentent ces trois
quarts j'ai mis la norvège là dedans
l'europe a perdu 15% de son pétrole
depuis 2006 c'est pas parce qu'on est
sage c'est parce que maintenant en moins
d'accord et la récession qu'on connaît
depuis 2007 et avec ce que je vous ai
dit avant une conséquence parfaitement
logique de ce que nous avons vécu depuis
2006 sur le pétrole
j'ai une bonne nouvelle pour vous donc
je vous disais tout à l'heure ça ne sert
à rien de dire qu'on veut que le pouvoir
d'achat ne soit pas compris mais par la
lutte contre le changement climatique
de toute façon je pense qu'il a baissé
pour le gaz c'est exactement pareil
la proportion n'est pas la même mais en
attendant le gaz est également à la
baisse en europe
ce qui veut dire soit dit en passant que
tous les gens quels qu'en soient les
justifications qui disent le nucléaire
cet or il vaut mieux remplacer par du
gaz qui est vachement bien pas sûr que
ce soit si facile
voilà quel est le potentiel du gaz du
gaz de schiste en france et en pologne
cumulés
ensuite tout ça est une affaire de
chiffre donc le poids tant d'autres un
non débat le gaz de schiste c'est pas un
débat c'est un non débat
epsilon ça ne change à peu près rien aux
conditions de marché et de volume du gaz
en europe et par ailleurs ça supposerait
de faire ça personnellement je pense que
la presse s'est focalisé sur deux sujets
qui n'en sont pas la fracturation c'est
un faux problème
les poudres de perlimpinpin et le pecq
vaisselle lacombe et sous terre c'est un
faux problème par contre ça c'est un
vrai problème
le vrai problème des gaz non
conventionnel c'est l'occupation en
surface
la france n'est pas les états unis on
n'est pas un pays désert par ailleurs il
ya des tas d'autres trucs je veux
heureusement pas le temps d'y venir sur
le droit milliers sur les conditions
économiques etc
mais je suis un très grand sceptique des
gaz de schiste au sens où je pense que
c'est pas le sujet enfin nous avons du
charbon sur terre et le charbon c'est
essentiellement dû aux chinois pour
l'augmentation récente cela étant les
chinois est aussi vous à chaque fois que
vous achetez un truc made in china à
vous acheter un truc mais ni charbon on
va terminer ce petit exposé introductif
avec une petite règle de trois que je
vous propose à partir de maintenant pour
voir où est ce que tout ça pourrait
aller plus tard alors marc est de 3
commence par dire que le pib mondial est
égal à lui même
j'espère que malgré les ventres vides on
sera à peu près d'accord là dessus je
multiplie et je divise par l'énergie ça
veut dire quoi cette histoire ça veut
dire que je fais apparaître un terme qui
s'appelle pib sur nrj pib sur nrj c'est
combien d'euros de valeur ajoutée je
crée pour les hommes
quand je modifie l'environnement à
hauteur de 20 kilowatts heure ajouté de
valeur un kilowatt heure c'est un
changement physique de l'environnement
donc je modifie l'environnement à
hauteur de 20 kilowatts heure en
déplaçant en tordant on vit sans
chauffeur froid 10 ans peu importe
combien d'euros pour les pour les hommes
je crée en faisant ça plus je crée
d'euros en modifiant peu l'environnement
et plus on dit que mon économie est
énergétiquement efficaces et je
multiplie par l'énergie et je ramène ça
aux individus donc le pib par personne
c'est à dire vos revenus
parce que par définition le pib par
personne c'est vos revenus un salaire et
rentrent agrégé c'est strictement égale
strictement égal à l'énergie par
personne fois l'efficacité énergétique
de l'économie
plus vous avez d'énergie plus vous
gagnez d'argent j'ai très exactement ce
que je vous ai raconté tout à l'heure
alors l'énergie par personne je voulais
montrer tout à l'heure ça augmente puis
s'arrête d'augmenter l'efficacité
énergétique de l'économie
ça augmente doucettement depuis quelques
dizaines d'années avant ce n'est pas
calculé le pib donc le point ne se pose
pas et donc le pib par personne me dit
ma petite règle de trois je dois
observer que pendant les trente
glorieuses
il croise est d'un peu plus de 3% par an
et depuis les chocs pétroliers d'un peu
plus de 1 alors voilà ce que ça a donné
en france vous voyez que le pib pardon
s'arrête de croître en 2007
voilà ce que ça donne dans le monde vous
avez bien les trente glorieuses où
s'accroît de 3 % par an c'est là c'est
la barre rouge qui est importante c'est
la moyenne par décennie et pour ce qu'on
a appelé parfois les trente piteuses
c'est à dire les 30 ans qui ont suivi le
choc pétrolier on est bien un pour cent
par an la france a fait des marches
d'escalier plutôt plus descendante et
donc vous voyez que quel que soit le
candidat à la présidence de la
république qui nous explique qu'on va
revenir au-dessus de 2% par an moi si
j'étais à votre place je me méfierais je
pense que le pétrole et le gaz n'empêche
de faire ça je vous disais tout à
l'heure le pétrole c'est un problème de
volume pas de prix vous avez ici un
graphique dans lequel encore une fois
pour chaque année entre 1960 et 2011 en
abscisse jeu mais le prix du baril et en
ordonnée le pib mondial si la théorie
disait que plus l'énergie vauchère moyen
de pib eh bien vous devriez voir un
nuage de points descendant circa quand
vous allez vers la droite du graphique
où le prix du pétrole augmente le pib
baisse d'accord on devrait avoir une
jauge de poing organisé en droite comme
ça c'est pas du tout ça qu'on observe
donc il n'y a pas de lien entre le pib
mondial et le prix du pétrole
0 c'est pas un sujet pour le pib mondial
quand le père du pétrole augmente c'est
triste pour nous
c'est vachement bien pour les
producteurs de pétrole et après ils nous
achètent le psg et les galeries
farfouille est donc il ya aucun problème
c'est pas un sujet pour le pib mondial
c'est un sujet pour nous par contre
parce que nous nous sommes importateurs
massif
alors voilà ce que donne la facture
énergétique de l'union européenne
multiplié par six en l'espace de dix ans
voilà un autre truc qui peut vous faire
réfléchir
depuis 1993 l'augmentation de ce qu'on
appelle la dette souveraine ce terreau
l'endettement de l'état est à peu près
égale à peu près égale à la quantité
d'argent qu'on a déboursé sur le même
laps de temps pour s'acheter du pétrole
et du gaz
alors nous on est des bons guignols
chacun d'eux s'est on tient mal nos
comptes etc
donc on va voir des gens sérieux les
allemands et vous voyez que c'est très
différent chez eux
donc c'est après le structurel ce que je
suis en train d'évoquer vraiment prime
structurelles
trois mots sur le changement climatique
pour finir vous savez que chaque
médaille a son revers sur une manière de
voir les choses sous un oeil optimiste
vous avez ici quelque chose qui
ressemble à ce que serait l'europe si
elle pas demain vous allez me dire s'il
n'y a pas d'eau mais pas de femmes on
s'en fout de savoir à quoi ressemble
l'europe puisque on n'y est pas donc ça
représente les écosystèmes qui serait là
si on ne l'avait pas défricher pour
faire de l'agriculture occuper l'espace
pour faire des routes des ponts des
villes etc
qu'est-ce qui aurait en europe
essentiellement de la forêt ça veut dire
que les conditions de température et
surtout de pluviométrie sont
suffisamment clémente pour que nous
ayons des forêts c'est à dire des
écosystèmes abondants on va dire voilà
l'europe de la dernière ère glaciaire il
ya vingt mille ans nous sommes au
dernier maximum glaciaire
la terre est beaucoup plus froide il ya
des mammouths spartoo vous savez soit
poil laineux
vous avez une énorme calotte de glace
qui est posé sur la scandinavie
la même chose se poser sur le canada
cette glace a pris tellement d'eau dans
l'océan pour se former que le niveau de
l'océan a baissé de 120 mètres donc le
havre n'est pas une cité portuaire et on
peut aller mettre la pâtée aux gallois
au rugby à pied point bas de la manche
et 115 mètres donc on peut y aller à
pied
eurotunnel fait faillite enfin bref donc
c'est un monde assez différents et vous
voyez que à ce moment là il fait froid
donc il fait plus sec et l'écosystème
installé sur l'europe c'est
essentiellement un écosystème de type
nord sibérien c'est de la steppe et de
la toundra c'est sec c'est froid c'est
pas agréable il pousse pas grand chose
et bien la différence de température
planétaire entre ces deux paysages et 5
degrés donc quand la terre est sorti de
la dernière ère glaciaire pour venir
dans l'air que nous connaissons la
planète s'est réchauffée de 5 à 50 5
degrés en quelques milliers d'années
regardez le résultat que ça a produit
alors celui là s'est produit à notre
avantage et puis ces produits sur un
monde où on était 5 millions de bons
hommes nomades 20 ans d'espérance de vie
à la naissance et ont pas de carte à la
cgt
donc ce problème là d'accord pas un
sujet le même genre de transition
s'appliquant en un siècle ou deux à sept
milliards de bipèdes sédentaires
sédentaires vous avez vos
infrastructures vos écoles vos habitudes
vos chambres etc vous avez pas partir
avec ça sur le dos pour les installer
chez le voisin qui en plus sera pas
d'accord
il est évident que ce genre de
transition dans un monde de 7 milliards
d'hommes sédentaires se terminera par
tous sauf la joie et la bonne humeur
ça sera un monde violent et chaotique
violent et chaotique donc quand le giec
qui va publier son cinquième rapport
d'évaluation dans très exactement 3
jours va vous dire on risque quelques
degrés en gros moi je vous le traduit
avec le langage de tous les jours on
risque la guerre voilà ce qu'on risque
mais pas avec les gens du bangladesh ou
et non avec nos voisins entre nous mêmes
parce que la compétition pour les
ressources deviendra trop forte pour que
la démocratie il résiste enfin je vais
terminer avec un plat de spaghettis
certains d'entre vous dans cette salle
sont dans des entreprises
alors je vais vous montrer que le
problème que je viens d'évoquer peut
s'inviter par des tas de portes et
fenêtres et qu' on n'est pas en train de
parler d'un problème qui se traitent en
silo page 3 du journal à côté des
problèmes sérieux contre est quand on a
le temps 1
mais de quelque chose qui s'invite
absolument partout dans la vie des
entreprises
il va y avoir je voulais 10 des tensions
sur l'approvisionnement fossiles alors
comme l'énergie est une commodité vendus
sur des marchés quand vous avez une
tension le prix devient volatile et en
entendrez des chocs ce qu'on constate en
ce moment absolument partout à ce moment
l'énergie devient plus cher et vous avez
de l'inflation induite par tous
puisqu'il ya de l'énergie partout par
des effets d'asservissement sur les
marchés vous avez également des tables
matières premières qu'ils deviennent
plus chers les serré
l'or et ses cracks re impact sur les
coûts mais comme vous n'avez pas assez
d'énergie c'est ça qui a provoqué la
hausse de prix par ailleurs vous avez
une récession et à ce moment là
récession vous impact vos recettes
alors ce que je suis en train de vous
faire là vous pouvez le faire sur l'état
sur une collectivité locale ou sur votre
propre budget enfin je veux dire c'est
toujours le même raisonnement le
changement climatique à l'oeuvre de
temps en temps nous prive de ressources
typiquement les grandes canicules qu'on
a maintenant à répétition font des
pressions très fortes sur les ressources
agricoles celles de 2010 a provoqué pour
partie le bazar du printemps arabe début
1 les pays la tunisie et l'egypte sont
de très gros importateur de céréales et
à ce moment vous avez bien là également
un impact sur les coûts sur le chiffre
d'affaires après il ya des gens par
exemple les clients qui peuvent dire
nous on va vouloir se soucier de cette
affaire et à ce moment si l'entreprise
ou la collectivité locales ou l'état
peut importe ne fait pas ce qu'il faut
pour répondre à cette attente
il ya un impact sur l'équilibré
économique parce que les gens se mettent
à faire autre chose que ce qu'on
attendrait de l'étape réglementé réguler
et c'est à ce moment il ya des impacts
c'est même son rôle je vous rappelle à
l'état de faire des règles du jeu les
banquiers peuvent se mettre de la partie
ils peuvent se dire toi mon coco tu va
investir dans un truc qui est trop
dépendant du pétrole directement ou
indirectement donc je te prête à trois
ans à 25% et si tu me rembourse pas je
t'envoie la mafia donc il va ya voir ça
commence à venir
ce genre de raisonnement 1 et à ce
moment si les gens sont dans un secteur
dans lequel ils sont par trop dépendants
de l'énergie fossile
ils peuvent plus financer leurs
investissements parce que la prime de
risque devient trop élevé et donc ça
accélère leur problème enfin il peut y
avoir un sujet de gens qui ont besoin
qu'ils sont qualifiés pour s'en occuper
et si ils sont pas là parce que recruter
suffisamment à l'avancé ou le moment
n'est pas encore au moment où le
problème n'est pas encore trop sial le
jour où le problème devient un peu plus
crucial bain les gens pour gérer pour
elles ne sont pas là et à ce moment vous
avez une pression supplémentaire
et enfin vous avez au milieu de tout ça
ça aurait mérité un débat à lui tout
seul les ong dont le métier est de
secouer le cocotier quoi qu'il en tombe
du reste puisque leur métier de secouer
pas trop de regard de sélectionner les
noix de coco et qui ont pour vocation de
mettre de l'agitation dans tout ce
tableau voilà j'ai dépassé de deux
minutes je suis absolument désolé pour
les organisateurs